aujourd'hui on parle colorimétrie lutte
pack de lutte et tout ça bien évidemment
vous le savez que ce que je vais dire
vous savez ce que je veux dire ce sera
juste après l'intro je viens prévisible
un truc de fou c'est un mais bon comme
ça la vie
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore je
suis ravie comme toujours de vous
retrouver sur cette chaîne
cette chaîne nous on parle de vidéos de
montage de captation de tout ça tout ça
donc si c'est quelque chose qui vous
plaît pensez à vous abonner en cliquant
sur le petit bouton prévu à cet effet
alors une des questions qui revient le
plus souvent dans les dm un stade dans
les commentaires et tout c'est comment
tu fais ta colonna colorimétrique
comment tu donnes cette teinte à ton
image alors je vous ai préparé quelque
chose qui devrait vous plaire
et puis on va regarder ça tout de suite
vous ai fait une petite démo voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et oui ma colorimétrie j'en ai fait des
luttes par des luttes qu'est ce que
c'est on en a fait une vidéo avec l'ami
adelin vous pouvez aller voir en
cliquant dans le lien dans la
description et où ça s'affiche sur les
côtés je sais jamais juge pense que je
serai jamais de quel côté ça s'affiche
donc pas ça s'affiche vous pouvez
cliquer dans cette vidéo on détaillé
exactement ce que c'était des luttes les
différents types de lutte
donc je vais pas revenir dessus mais
grosso modo si vous avez la flemme
d'aller jusque là une lutte c'est un
genre de filtres c'est un genre de
préréglages qu'on va pouvoir appliquer à
une vidéo et donc pour vous simplifier
la vie
je vous en ai fait un pack de neuf lutte
différentes que vous allez pouvoir
télécharger mais avant de vous expliquer
où vous allez pouvoir les trouver je
vais vous expliquer comment bien les
utiliser d'abord ce sont des luttes de
look donc ça va donner une teinte à
votre image et ses luttes elles ont été
élaborées à partir de ma caméra et de
mon profil d'image profil d'image que je
vous donne dans le pack de lutte bien
entendu ce qui veut dire que si vous
utilisez une caméra sony et le profil
d'image que je vous donnais pas le
résultat sera le même que ce que je vous
montre
mais rassurez vous j'ai détesté avec
plein d'autres caméras avec d'autres
profils d'image même de l'iphone je dis
un grand merci aux gars de little walk
of fame
je vous mets leurs chaînes dans la
description ils ont fait une vidéo à
l'iphone onze pros et appliquer la lutte
blockbuster dessus et franchement je
trouve que ça rend hyper bien donc pour
ça pour vous dire que pour avoir un
résultat à l'identique bah oui il faut
du sony font le même profil images mais
que vous allez voir on va regarder dans
final cut
comment on peut utiliser ça sur un autre
au fil des images ça marchera également
ah oui et puis ça fonctionne sur davinci
et ça fonctionne aussi sur premier but
c'est universel
donc quel que soit votre logiciel du
moment qu'ils acceptent les luttes bas
ça fonctionnera y aura pas de souci
c'est cool allez on y va ce parti alors
qu'on il faudrait faire j'ai importé un
rush ici dans ma timeline je vais aller
dans les effets ici et je vais aller
chercher les faits lutte personnalisés
je vais l'appliquer à mon plan alors
bien entendu on peut le faire sur un
hadj cnh player
si on a plein de plans pour éviter de
faire la colo sur chaque plan le lien
vers la vidéo qui explique ce qu'est un
agent payeur s'affiche en haut de votre
écran
maintenant que j'ai appliqué mon effet
il ne se passe rien
num je vais aller ici d'un inspecteur et
dans lutte ici alors moi j'ai déjà les
luttes importés mais je peux aller
choisir une lutte personnalisés et ici
vous n'aurez qu'à sélectionner le
dossier et ouvrir pour importer les lucs
ensuite tout simplement ce que je vais
faire c'est aller chercher ici une lutte
alors on va prendre moi par exemple
j'aime bien
blockbuster up alors elle est un tout
petit peu trop prononcé donc je vais
baisser ici l'opacité le mixage a on
peut en mettre plus ou moins là si je
vais tout à fait à gauche j'ai plus du
tout de la lutte si je vais ici au
milieu j'ai la moitié on va dire de la
lutte qui peut servir éventuellement de
base à votre colo après derrière moi ici
je vais la mettre à ce niveau là et moi
j'utilise un profil flat comme vous
pouvez voir ici si je décoche les faits
l'image et des contrastes et dé saturer
un pas au niveau d'un blog
mais c'est quand même flat donc si vous
utilisez un profil qui n'est pas flat
n'hésitez pas à descendre le mixage de
la lutte puisque forcément les couleurs
seront beaucoup plus prononcer là dessus
ça veut pas dire que ça marche pas ça
veut juste dire qu'il faut baisser un
petit peu le mixage autre chose si vous
utilisez du log il faudra utiliser une
lutte de conversion 1 pour passer du
format log oreilles 709 mais ça c'est
très simple si vous utilisez du lobe
vous devez être habitué à ça autre chose
la lutte en soit c'est bien mais moi
j'aime bien rajouter un effet donné tout
et hop on va aller chercher cet effet
ici on valeur ajoutée et - généralement
je le mets à 3 voilà ça va donner un
petit peu plus de piquer à notre image
un petit peu plus de 2
sharp naissent voilà venir de précision
là dessus
éventuellement on peut rajouter aussi si
on veut les fameuses letter box 1 pour
donner cet aspect cette émulation de
cinéma on va mettre ici 2,35 comme un
ratio voilà on peut gérer love 7 pour
que l'image soit bien centrer et voilà
c'est tout alors après pareil en vous
pouvez tester les différentes luttes ici
on a un blanc et noir qui est sympa
j'aime bien aussi le vintage par exemple
aussi qui donne un petit côté un peu
polaroïd à l'image voilà et détend un
peu magenta moins celui là moi je trouve
il est il est marqué mais je trouve
sympa et puis voilà je vous laisserai
essayé tous les autres puis vous dire
est ce que vous en pensez
et voilà c'est aussi simple que ça alors
où vous pouvez trouver le pack des
luttes que j'ai créé et bien tout
simplement dans le lien dans la
description ça se passe sur le shop yu
ti ce pack de l'utiliser à 15 euros
pendant une semaine à partir
d'aujourd'hui donc voilà profitez-en
après il sera à 30 euros est dedans vous
trouvez les neuf lutte vous trouver le
profil d'image et puis il n'ya plus qu'à
foncer
voilà faire de la colle et puis comme un
bonheur n'arrive jamais seul et que bon
on approche un petit peu de noël et bien
je me suis dit que j'allais refaire une
promo sur la formation final cut là que
vous trouvez dans la description
également il ya 30% de réduction qu'elle
est à 69 euros donc cela aussi si vous
voulez apprendre comment bien démarrer
avec final cut et prendre tous les bons
réflexes bas on pouvait y aller et puis
voilà les amis si cette vidéo vous a plu
vous mettez le traditionnel coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui situe
en dessous cette vidéo vous pensez à
vous abonner à cliquer sur la cloche
pour être notifié des prochaines vidéos
et puis moi je vous dis comme d'habitude
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo comment ça fait
plaisir d'avoir un petit peu de temps là
pour faire des vidéos youtube alors
j'avoue j'en ai fait pas mal d'affilée 1
jamais de tourner quelques-unes
d'affilée mais ça foire ça fait plaisir
c'est ya plein de taf qui arrive en 2020
mais là j'ai la période tout pile pour
faire ce que j'ai envie et ça c'est trop
cool ça fait plaisir
voilà juste plaisir merci